[Aplausos]
en nuestra niñez muchas veces queremos
que nuestros metros cuadrados en los
cuales hemos crecido y nos hemos creado
son lugares maravillosos aún no hemos
salido a explorar el mundo y creemos que
todo el mundo es increíble como estos
metros cuadrados los cuales vivimos mi
amiga marjorie de ocho años en el cerro
tecana pintó y dibujo esa imagen para
ella es un paraíso en el cual haya
crecido en el cual ella se ha creado en
el cual para ella es increíblemente
hermoso con vietnam con naturaleza con
animales y ella cree que más allá de las
dos metros cuadrados que haya crecido es
igual pero no sabemos la realidad de lo
que está allá afuera ese paraíso que te
estoy contando ya te mencioné es el
cerro tecana ese cerro en el cual en
santa ana se encuentra cerca de la
ciudad y tú tienes una cruz en la cima y
tú puedes ver todas las sedes de ahí
pero ese paraíso está en peligro de
extinción
yo aún recuerdo a mis 12 años cuando yo
caminaba a hacer colegio en el cual yo
estudiaba el poder observar este rote
canadá de frente a mí y ver como lo
quemaba
como lo está la van a ver como estaba
siendo destruido y en aquel tiempo
recuerda saben séptimo grado yo lo
miraba yo decía primero dios alguien
puede hacerse cargo de este cerro que
alguien por favor lo proteja que alguien
lo defienda nunca me imaginé que cuando
los años pasaran yo iba a estar al
frente del cerro nunca me imaginé que
ahora lleva sal cuerda luther bote cana
y que muchos se iban a ir conmigo
también a poderlo proteger ese es un
paraíso que está en peligro de extinción
yo di vida en este cerro en los últimos
tres años trabajando por él
restaurándolo haciéndole frente a los
problemas ambientales pero sigue y está
latente y sabemos que lo vamos a
recuperar este es un paraíso en peligro
extinción no sé cuántos de ustedes viven
cerca de un paraíso en peligro de
extinción cuántos de ustedes tienen la
oportunidad de estar en esos espacios
verdes esos espacios llenos de
naturaleza llenos de animales no sé
cuántos de aquí viven en un lugar así
pero en este momento yo los quiero
llevar un viaje al pasado cuando aún
existían los humanos cuando un que
existía la naturaleza la vegetación
fauna el mar los ríos y todo sin que el
humano hubiera dicho nada así que por
favor yo le puede pedir que cierren sus
ojos que cierren sus ojos todos por
favor respiren profundo y se den cuenta
que estamos viajando al pasado escuchan
ustedes esas aves
pueden sentir la frescura pueden darse
cuenta como la naturaleza está frente a
nosotros si vamos caminando
hay un río
podemos ver el agua cristalina es un
manantial esa agua que quisiéramos tomar
al parecer va a llover
y los animales están felices está
regocijando se viene la lluvia
ahora para que usted no se mojen vamos a
regresar el presente día con sus ojos
cerrados ya viene la tormenta va a ser
muy fuerte pero todo es natural todo es
verde
ahora vamos a dejar es el presente vamos
a regresar al mundo en el cual vivimos
cierren sus ojos imagínense lo que está
pasando
y ahora vamos a regresar a la realidad
cuántos de ustedes escuchan esos sonidos
todos los días cuando usted están
traumados con esos pitos no hay
naturaleza no hay árboles solo pavimento
y puros vehículos abran sus ojos
este es el paraíso que nosotros tenemos
estén ahí la tasajera en usulután a
donde desemboca el río lempa esto ya no
es un paraíso
este es un desierto ese es un cementerio
de plástico donde busca minas
y para ti has lo que son botellas
plásticas lo que son platos de dura
packs lo que son todos los desechables y
muchas otras que vienen con la corriente
del río lempa eso es lo que nosotros
tenemos en nuestro país ese es un
paraíso el cual ya se extinguió es un
paraíso que si te das cuenta no creo yo
que hayan sido los animales no creo que
han sido las plantas quienes crees que
han provocado ese cementerio de plástico
nosotros los humanos no sé cuántos de
ustedes hoy tomaron agua en una botella
plástica no sé cuántos de ustedes este
día tiraron una botella a la calle no sé
cuántos de ustedes consumieron este día
una lata
o algo que viniera en un frasco de
plástico y lo tiraron o lo dejaron un
basurero no sabemos dónde va a ir a
parar no sabemos en qué lugar va a
terminar posiblemente habían relleno
sanitario o posiblemente vaya a otro
lugar en nuestro país del 100 por ciento
de lo que nosotros desechamos sólo el 5%
se recicla te imaginas el 95% hacia
dónde va termina ríos termina en bosques
también un relleno sanitario y
posiblemente va a terminar en la boca de
un animal en el océano posiblemente va a
terminar en el intestino de algún animal
5 % de plástico el que se recicla en
nuestro país
no solamente es el tema de los desechos
también el tema del agua cuantos han
estado en el río acelhuate cuántos meses
en otros ríos los cuales están
contaminados este río el río sucio o el
río sauce en santa ana donde bueno
soportase el olor cuando pasas por ahí y
te preguntas por qué las ciudades están
utilizando los ríos como inodoros porque
si te das cuenta todo lo que viene por
el río son desechos orgánicos e
inorgánicos te das cuenta todos los
desechos que vienen de plástico de dura
packs de latas de tela de muchas otras
cosas que posiblemente ustedes o alguien
de ustedes no pudo haber arrojado
posiblemente usted lo pusieron en la
basura y vino el camión se lo llevó pero
en el camino se le cayó y se fue en el
río nosotros sabemos que va a pasar
después de eso es eso es el agua en
nuestro país a nivel de centroamérica
tenemos un récord el 90 por ciento de
nuestra agua está contaminada
el agua más contaminada y centroamérica
creo que nadie le da orgullo saber que
tu agua es la más contaminada de
centroamérica es algo que tendría
decepcionar es algo que te debería de
hacer sentir mal y te debes hacer sentir
vergüenza porque nuestro país debería de
caracterizarse por poder proteger la
naturaleza y no por estar la destruyendo
y estaba contaminando yo te hable de
cerro tecana
un paraíso que esté en peligro extinción
y desde hace tres años que estamos
trabajando en él no te puedo decir que
hemos logrado el cien por cien de lo que
queríamos hemos sido atacados por temas
de quema por temas de tala y esta imagen
para mí es un poco traumática porque yo
he estado a metros del cerro tecana
cuando lo están quemando y escuchar a
las autoridades decirme no es que tenés
que esperar que se apague el sol y yo
estar a unos metros escuchando las
llamas saber que a unos metros las aves
los mamíferos los reptiles se están
quemando están moviendo calcinados
yo no poder hacer nada me dicen ni
siquiera se te ocurra irte a vos solo a
querer apagar ese fuego porque al final
te vas a quemar voz y se van a quemar
las personas que te sigan pero no te no
podemos hacer nada así que espera te que
se apague el sol o es algo que
verdaderamente es triste saber que algo
que estás protegiendo sabe que un
paraíso en peligro de extinción lo están
destruyendo
más de 109 incendios han sido
registrados a nivel nacional no
solamente fue el cerro tecana fueron
otros cerros fueron otras propiedades
posiblemente ustedes cerca de sus casas
vieron fuego posiblemente ustedes cerca
del aeropuerto han visto fuego
posiblemente ustedes en cualquier lugar
de este país visualizan fuego visualizan
incendios que no son provocados por los
animales no son provocados por las
plantas es provocado por todos nosotros
los que no tenemos conciencia de poder
proteger la naturaleza más de 109
incendios registrados
posiblemente hubieron muchos más que no
fueron registrados te imaginas que eso
pase cada año no sé desde hace cuántos
años están sucediendo más de 100
incendios al año pero te imaginas lo que
pasó ahora cuántos animales murieron en
estos incendios no es que la gente vino
y voy a sacar a todos estos animales me
lo voy a dar un lugar seguro y ahora voy
a incendiar no el que yo lo voy a
incendiar yo quiero incendiarlo y se
incendió y murieron muchos animales
no solamente en el tema de agua no
solamente el tema de desecho ni el tema
de quema cuando yo
nací crecí cerca de una finca en santa
anna
que si con ellas yo recuerdo que mi
niñez yo entraba a la finca a comer
fruta frutas que no se encontraba en
otros lugares encontraba plantas
mamíferos que no los había visto en
otros lugares y hace dos años decidieron
notificarlo y yo recuerdo las sierras
estar las escuchando cuando despertaba y
escuchar las sierras y es decir no ya
están talando un árbol que yo denuncié
los pararon dos meses pero el poder
económico pudo más y ahora está
notificado ahora ese paraíso que yo con
el cual yo crecí ahora este extinto
ahora está muerto ahora en cemento es
pavimento y es todo lo gris que te
puedas imaginar y nada verde de lo que
vos crees eso fue traumático para mí yo
recuerdo que mi casa escuchaba esas
tierras escuchamos cuando le estaban
pegando con el machete a las ramas y
decidir irme de mi casa asia muy lejos
donde fuera y regresar de noche porque
soria no estaban trabajando cuando las
autoridades me decían mira no puedes
hacer nada tener cuidado me decía porque
algo usted puede pasar porque el poder
económico es fuerte porque es peligroso
pero decía no puedo abandonar aquel
lugar en el cual yo crecí estuve
sufriendo por algún tiempo pero al final
ésta es consecuencia lo que sucedió es
una imagen de uno de tantos árboles de
más de 100 árboles que fueron talados y
verdaderamente con tristeza uno puede
darse cuenta que la misma humanidad está
destruyendo el planeta
pero aún más tristeza saber que nuestro
país menos del 10 por ciento de todo su
territorio nacional stafford estado
menos del 10 por ciento eso significa
que todo todo nuestro territorio más del
90% está deforestado el suelo ha sido
cambiado para su uso hay posiblemente
pavimento hay cemento hay ganadería hay
pastos pero no hay bosques y no se están
protegiendo
si nos alejamos del salvador y viéramos
desde el océano nuestro país
posiblemente lo viéramos así con humo
quemándose siendo desforestado sufridos
contaminados no hay vida no hay nada que
nosotros vamos a decir él salvo está
protegiendo nuestro planeta
el salvor es haciendo algo por la
biodiversidad que se está perdiendo
pero no solamente son esos problemas hay
muchos más por ejemplo la contaminación
del aire y nuestros vehículos
me imagino que algunos de ustedes habrán
venido caminando bienvenido en bicicleta
y no emitieron dióxido de carbono no
ahora muchos posiblemente venimos en un
bus que iba tirando por todos lados
muchos de ustedes está viviendo en un
vehículo y tal vez sube su vecino bien
en el vehículo de él y nunca se pusieron
de acuerdo para venir los dos juntos así
evitar algunas emisiones de dióxido de
carbono la ganadería es otro problema
porque se está expandiendo la frontera
la ganadería y se está reduciendo la
frontera forestal la destrucción de la
biodiversidad a veces hablamos de
sembrar árboles a veces hablamos de
rescatar la naturaleza pero se nos
olvida el término biodiversidad qué es
lo que verdaderamente el equilibro del
planeta de qué sirve un planeta verde
sin la biodiversidad de qué sirve un
planeta este digámoslo así protegiéndose
si nos está protegiendo su vida
silvestre si no está protegiendo esos
animales insectos y toda la mayor
diversidad que pueda haber en un bosque
de que sirve de nada otro problema son
los permisos ambientales el poder
económico es tan fuerte que consigue los
permisos ambientales así por así y vos
te das cuenta que hay luchas que uno
hace y no la gana porque el empresa tal
el pago los permisos ambientales y tiene
el permiso de talar todo lo que él
quiera yo me enfrentado a eso y no es
tan fácil cuando vos sos un simple
ciudadano y la grandes empresa elena en
industria quiere talar quiere quemar
pues bueno el dinero mueve poderes y el
dinero mueve decisiones y te das cuenta
que fácilmente consigan permisos
ambientales aunque hayan especies en
peligro de extinción
también te das cuenta que nuestros
gobernantes el tema ambiental lo tienen
de último es la última prioridad si te
das cuenta todas las leyes que se
discuten todos los acuerdos a los que
llegan todas las ordenanzas que se ponen
las alcaldías no tiene nada que ver con
el tema ambiental y te da tristeza saber
que ven el problema enfrente saben que
el cambio climático está haciendo
destrucción ven las inundaciones de sus
ciudades y bueno siguen pensando en
hacer calles siguen pensando en hacer
colonias cuando deberían de pensar en
hacer bosques cuando deberían de pensar
en proyecto en proteger la biodiversidad
eso es algo que verdaderamente es
lamentable a nuestro país también hay
leyes acuerdos protocolos ordenanzas y
pactos a nivel mundial que no se cumplen
tenemos tantos meses con el acuerdo de
escazú que queremos que se pueda
ratificar que se pueda firmar el acuerdo
de parís hay tantos acuerdos que a nivel
mundial te dicen tienes que proteger la
naturaleza de esta forma de esta forma y
de la otra y nuestros países como miren
no nos interesa eso mejor voy a poner
publicidad de algo más pero voy a hacer
algo que me dé votos allá hay tantas
cosas que a nivel mundial es una
urgencia y nos damos cuenta que no
estamos haciendo nada en el salvador
el planeta entero se está quemando y
este mapa es de hace unos días cuando el
amazonas estuvo con un incendio
demasiado fuerte y que posiblemente no
se había registrado desde hace muchos
años o nunca pero no solamente fue
cuestión de la amazonía fue áfrica fue
siberia son muchos países y esos puntos
rojos que vos ves en el mapa son todos
los incendios que en el mes de julio
estaban pasando a nivel mundial y te das
cuenta que no solo fue un incendio en el
salvador hay miles y miles y miles de
incendios a nivel mundial cuánta
biodiversidad está perdiendo cuánto está
contribuyendo al calentamiento global y
después estamos quejándonos de los
huracanes después nos estamos quejando
de que los polos se están derritiendo
cuando nosotros mismos lo estamos
quemando yo te apuesto que ningún
elefante provoco estos incendios yo te
apuesto que ningún perrito hice esos
incendios fueron los seres humanos
y eso te hace ver que nuestro problema
no solamente es local sino que es un
florero un problema planetario es algo
que sigue en el salvador
estoy destruyendo la flora y la fauna le
va a afectar a rusia y si rusia hace lo
mismo el afecta al salvador si china
hace lo mismo le afecta el salvador y
siempre así se hace lo mismo le afecta
al salvador todo un sistema de nuestro
planeta está conectado y todo lo que
pasa en algún lugar le va a afectar a
todos así que no podemos huir de nuestra
responsabilidad no podemos decir no me
compete no me interesa sino que cada
cosa que nosotros hagamos de forma local
va a afectar de manera global nos hemos
dado cuenta que nos equivocamos el
camino que lleva la humanidad es
insostenible el camino que nosotros
llevamos solamente hay destrucción hay
extinción hay pérdida de todo y hay
muerte no hay nada bueno que venga de un
futuro si lo seguimos llevando como
estamos hasta ahora el ser humano ha
tratado de mejorar la vida del hombre
desde hace muchos años hemos tenido
cuatro revoluciones industriales que han
buscado que la humanidad pueda mejorar
en tecnología que la humanidad sea más
fácil su vida etcétera estamos
en la cuarta revolución pronto viene la
quinta revolución industrial y se están
preguntando vamos a conquistar el
espacio vamos a llegar a marte vamos a
hacer vuelos comerciales de un planeta a
otro vamos a orbitar o están pensando
también se llama va a poder manejar el
mundo cuántico lo más pequeño que puede
existir en el xxi en nuestro planeta el
mundo cuántico es otra de las fronteras
que ellos quieren explorar pero nadie
sanando nada ambiental nadie está
hablando de algo de la naturaleza
todos están enfocando en el espacio en
lo más pequeño cuando tenéis tanto que
hacer cuando tienes tantas cosas que
pueden mejorar pero no se está pensando
en ello y sabes que todo y de la
naturaleza depende el futuro de la
humanidad así como las serpientes
sabemos de que tenemos que estar a
defensiva porque al final todos nos
están provocando daño a nosotros todo
nos está afectando a nosotros todos nos
pueden matar a nosotros no sabemos
cuándo vamos a morir posiblemente una
enfermedad respiratoria por el tema del
humo posiblemente por dengue por algo
que se multiplicaron los ángulos por el
calor y por el agua estancada y por la
contaminación que hay entonces tenemos
que hacer algo y como la serpiente es
estar a la defensiva
para lo cual yo te propongo que dejemos
de pensar en términos de revoluciones
industriales y pasemos a hablar de
revoluciones ambientales gaby neto
margarita y yo somos parte de esa
revolución ambiental y lo mismo quiero y
lo mismo deseamos nosotros que todos
ustedes sean parte de la revolución
ambiental todas las revoluciones antes
han empezado por una persona se
multiplicaron en cinco y si fueron
multiplican hasta que fueron millones de
personas que empezaron a hacer estas
revoluciones ustedes están dispuesto a
revolucionar lo que está pasando nuestro
planeta ustedes están pensando en que ya
no podemos vivir y coexistir como lo
estamos haciendo es el día de ahora si
no estás de acuerdo en eso entonces
unite a la revolución verdaderamente
revolución hemos este planeta
dejémosle al espacio a las plantas y a
los animales de poder sobrevivir después
coexistir sin amor a la gente como se
protege la biodiversidad encima ya la
gente cómo se hace desarrollo sostenible
un día en la cima del cerro tecana
viendo la ciudad santa anna
pensando yo puedo revolucionar como
persona también por revolucionar a mis
amigos también puede revolucionar toda
una ciudad y si revolución una ciudad
por revolucionar un país y si revolución
un país por revolucionar el planeta
porque no hacer lo que otros lo han
hecho entonces decidimos nosotros
generar la primera revolución ambiental
y para eso te voy a dar muchas de las
cosas que vamos a hacer para hacer una
revolución 1 cambiemos nuestro lenguaje
cuántos de ustedes hablan en términos de
recursos naturales cuántos de ustedes
siguen hablando en términos de medio
ambiente cuando sabes que eso estás
hablando lo desde un punto de vista
económico los recursos naturales cuando
habla de recursos naturales es que tengo
estos recursos para poder generar
ciertas cosas para poder generar capital
para poder generar ciertos productos y
yo están viendo como algo que es
utilizable porque no hablamos de bienes
naturales no generamos un respeto para
la naturaleza porque hablamos de bienes
comunes porque no hablamos de un
ambiente completo y dejamos de hablar de
medio ambiente porque un medio de
extracción porque es uno en el cual yo
puedo generar riqueza puedo generar
productos etcétera
también actuamos en función de
ecosistemas nativos nuestro planeta es
tan perfecto que en cada región ha
puestos las especies nativas de flora
las especies nativas de fauna porque
traerá árboles de otros continentes
porque es sembrar árboles de otros
países cuando nuestro país tiene riqueza
natural que es nativa cuando nuestro
país tiene suelos ricos para poder
nutrir este tipo de especies de árboles
que al mismo tiempo nutren a los
animales y son nativos y no se van pero
cuando estos venimos a querer sembrar
árboles que son de otros países y que
son invasores atraemos especies
invasoras y desequilibramos todo el
ecosistema implementemos la economía
circular ya no sigamos con el consumismo
los encuentros de ustedes la ropa que
andan puesta la van a usar ahora y
posiblemente la van a votar el día de
mañana posiblemente le vamos a dar 5
veces no sé cuántos de ustedes utilizan
su ropa muchas veces o solamente esperan
que se lea un ojito o se ponga un
poquito rara y yo la voy a votar eso es
economía lineal a donde solamente
pensamos en consumir en comprar en
ponernos sin desechar tenemos que pensar
en economía circular donde tenemos que
imitar a la naturaleza
que nada desperdicia donde tenemos que
entender y conocer de dónde proviene un
producto cuál es el uso que le voy a dar
y hacia dónde va evolucionamos las
energías renovables ya tenemos energía
solar energía eólica pero tenemos que
evolucionar las porque aún están
generando un impacto pequeño pero
negativo al ecosistema y al medio
ambiente
instalaremos una movilidad sostenible
usemos la bicicleta caminemos o hagamos
carpool que la gente podamos ir muchos y
no estar ocupando tantos espacios para
hacer tráfico para generar mayor sido de
carbono para generar más estrés para
generar muchos problemas más aprendamos
a rechazar si te das cuenta cuando te
hablan de las tres erres rechazar a
veces no está y debería de ser la
primera nosotros tendríamos que tener
estar pensando en rechazar materiales en
rechazar prácticas en rechazar leyes en
rechazar derechos que hacen que la
naturaleza sea destruida tenemos que
aprender a pensar en rechazar ya no
solamente repetir reciclar restaurar
reducir todas las que existen tengamos
una que sea la primera y que eso sea
rechazar probamos los shows y estoy
aburrido de ver tanta gente que dice yo
cuido la naturaleza y solo salen con la
foto imagino que algunos de ustedes se
han dado cuenta de políticos hay
personas que llegan a las actividades
ambientales solo a tomarse una foto y
decir ah yo estoy ayudando al medio
ambiente pero su ejemplo te dice lo peor
de ellos su ejemplo se da a conocer que
está enseñando la naturaleza
olvidémonos de volvemos a vender
saliendo las fotografías para que vean
que ser cuando el medio ambiente
hagámoslo
seamos ejemplo y por favor hagamos que
la gente lo repita acostumbrémonos a
denunciar eso es muy importante porque
al final el poder económico dice bueno
si la gente no dice nada y nadie se pone
a decirme algo pues yo sigo haciéndolo
pues cuando esas voces empiezan a
multiplicarse y empiezan a aumentar los
que están denunciando va a ser mucho más
fuerte la resistencia y vamos a poder
hacer que todas las cosas cambien
evitemos nos exigir exijamos nuestros
gobernantes a los gobiernos locales a
nuestra familia a nuestros padres a
nuestros hermanos a nuestros a nuestros
primos a todos exijámosles que por favor
puedan ayudar y puedan restaurar la
naturaleza y otra cosa muy importante
que se las quiero pedir ahora es que
eliminemos la comodidad es muy bonito
estar sentado escuchando lo que estoy
diciendo pero es muy difícil salir y
cambiar lo que estamos haciendo es lo
más difícil y es lo que yo les pido que
por favor empiecen a hacerlo porque así
empezamos a revolucionar cuando tan solo
nos quedamos en la idea de hacer algo
bueno por la naturaleza y qué bonito se
escuchó lo que dijo no hacemos nada
muriendo árboles están muriendo animales
lo que tenemos que hacer es cuando
salgamos y es más ahorita que ustedes me
están escuchando piensen en qué es lo
que ustedes pueden hacer cuando llega a
su casa piensen en lo que ustedes puedan
hacer ahora mismo para cambiar la
realidad ambiental en la cual estamos
viviendo pero lo más importante de todos
por favor por favor por favor actuemos
ya ya dejemos de hablar ya dejemos de
estar dándole largas a las cuestiones si
te das cuenta cada día mueren animales
cada día se extinguen plantas cada día
mueren personas por temas de cambio
climático cada día hay catástrofes
naturales que no son provocadas solo por
el planeta es una reacción de lo que
nosotros provocamos y no tenemos sólo
por ellos posiblemente digamos los
animales no les pasa nada pero te das
cuenta que muchos animales tienen
lugares que no deberían y están muriendo
están muriendo de hambre están muriendo
enfermedades están muriendo de muchas
cosas pero no solo son ellos también son
aquellas animales en los océanos se está
calentando el planeta se está calentando
su ecosistema se están quemando en el
océano están muriendo de calor
se están derritiendo los polos están
muriendo se están siguiendo por nosotros
están comiendo plástico
y también en países tan pequeños y tan
extraordinarios que también muy bien por
nuestra culpa sus árboles están siendo
talados a donde ellos se alimentaban
toda la naturaleza y la riqueza en la
cual yo se nutrían está muriendo y
también nos estamos matando se acuerdan
cuando empezamos la charla que lo lleve
un paraíso que en el pasado
acostumbrémonos a multiplicar este tipo
de paraíso rescatemos los pongámonos de
acuerdo y generemos nuevos bosques
pongámonos de acuerdo y generemos nuevos
espacios de biodiversidad ya no dejemos
que los demás nos están imponiendo
colonias residenciales que estén
segmentando todo nuestra revolución
tiene que ir más allá y tienes que
pensar en volver verde un planeta tiene
que pensar en descontaminar el agua
tiene que pensar en beneficiar la
biodiversidad
algo muy importante es de que no podemos
estar llorando por lo que nos dejaron en
el pasado sino por reclamarle a mi
abuelo a mi papá porque tal vez no hizo
nada y tenemos que saber que soy
responsable de lo que venga futuro lo
que me van a preguntar mis hijos los que
vamos a plantar mis nietos mis sobrinos
todos vamos a preguntar a mi mira caleb
y cuando vos podías hacer algo lo
hiciste como va a quedar como no fíjate
solo fui a hablar haya mucha gente que
hicieran algo yo no hice nada no verdad
y ustedes van a decirle a sí escuché una
charla me que me habló del tema natural
pero pensé que había tiempo todavía para
hacer algo pero no me imaginé que iba a
ser tan corto ese tiempo que voy a no
tienes agua voy a no tener bosque bueno
sabe ni siquiera que es un lobo bueno
sabes que es un puma bueno sabes que un
animal vivo porque ya se extinguieron
todos así que por favor nosotros somos
los responsables de lo que va a pasar en
el futuro somos responsables de cambiar
este rumbo somos responsables de generar
un desarrollo sostenible somos
responsables de cambiar esta realidad y
por favor hagamos una revolución
ambiental muchas gracias
[Aplausos]